dès qu'on s'intéresse un petit peu aux
grandes idéologies politiques on voit
vite que tout tourne un petit peu autour
du problème de la répartition du travail
et ce n'est pas étonnant puisque la
répartition du travail est typiquement
un problème de dilemme du prisonnier
l'idéal individuel c'est de profiter du
travail des autres alors bien sûr les
capitalistes vont typiquement dire que
c'est ce que font les gens du qui vivent
des aides sociales alors que les anti
capitalistes vont typiquement dire que
c'est ce que font ceux qui possèdent les
moyens de production ok mais que dirait
un économiste la théorie économique
dominante pose le capital les machines
plus l'argent qui sert à
l'investissement et le travail
nécessairement effectuées par des
humains comme base de toute production
économique des biens et des services et
donc chacun profite à la fois du travail
et du capital de tout le monde et pour
donner les incentives à chacun de
contribuer par son travail ou par son
capital des systèmes de rémunération ont
été mises en place et comme pour
n'importe quel autre marché ce sont les
mécanismes de l'offre et de la demande
qui permettent de définir la
rémunération des travailleurs et donc
des capitalistes parce qu'une fois que
les travailleurs ont été payés et bien
il ne reste plus que les bénéfices qui
vont aux capitalistes
certains économistes vont même plus loin
et affirme que ce point d'équilibré que
le marché de l'emploi permet de trouver
correspond à la juste rémunération de
chacun autrement dit dans un marché
libre le médecin le trader l'actionnaire
l'avocat le chauffeur de bus ou encore
l'éboueur sont tous rémunérés à la
hauteur de leur juste contribution selon
ce modèle économique basique votre
rémunération est ce que les autres sont
prêts à payer pour votre travail
étant donné notamment la concurrence
qu'il ya entre ceux capables de fournir
le travail que fournissent et et la
demande qu'il y a un an le travail que
vous fournissez et c'est ainsi que le
marché donc nous tous par le biais de
nos choix de consommation a déterminé
que certains seraient mieux payés que
d'autres conclusions le marché du
travail donc la rencontre de l'offre et
de la demande de travailleurs est
aujourd'hui l'outil de mesure qui permet
de déterminer la manière dont les
revenus vont être distribués alors il ya
quand même plusieurs problèmes avec
cette théorie
pour commencer on peut se demander si le
marché du travail est bien l'équilibré
c'est-à-dire s'il ya bien une rencontre
l'offre et la demande oui parce que le
modèle de l' équilibre des marchés
reposent sur des hypothèses quant même
discutable mais ce n'est pas tout il est
aussi difficile de prouver que si jamais
il y à bien un équilibre de tous les
marchés entre offre et demande
cette succession d'équilibrés représente
la seule combinaison possible ça vient
notamment du fait que théoriquement la
courbe de la demande agrégée pour être
tout à fait ressembler à ça or s'il
existe plusieurs combinaisons d'
équilibre alors laquelle choisir
laquelle permettrait d'obtenir le
résultat le plus juste et même là le
problème c'est que la juste rémunération
des travailleurs au sens économique n'a
a priori aucune raison d'être adéquat
pour bien vivre le fait que près de 9
millions de personnes vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté en france signifie
t'il que l' équilibre que nous avons
choisie n'est pas le bon un utilitarisme
dirais que la rémunération juste du
travail n'est pas forcément moral car
elle ne maximisent pas nécessairement le
bonheur général d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises dans l'histoire des
civilisations
on a remis en cause la rémunération que
les travailleurs méritent en régulant le
marché du travail mais les incentives
pour travailler ne sont pas uniquement
financiers
ils sont aussi et peut-être surtout
sociaux et oui on a tous envie de dire
intuitivement que travailler c'est bien
c'est contribuer à la société
à tel point qu'aujourd'hui on attend des
travailleurs qu'ils aillent travailler
même lorsqu'il s'agit d'une période
creuse et qu'il n'y a pas grand chose à
faire
plus généralement un argument de
sélection de groupes comme celui dont on
a parlé dans l'épisode 27 nous invite à
penser que seules les sociétés qui
sacralise le travail ont survécu ce
n'est sans doute pas un hasard si l'une
des plus grandes puissances économiques
mondiales a fait du travail de
l'american dream un symbole cet american
dream c'est l'idée selon laquelle
quiconque quelle que soit son origine et
ses moyens initiaux peut devenir
milliardaire à la sueur de son front
sauf que d'après le travail de thomas
piketty cocorico la possibilité de
s'extraire d'un statut social
défavorable en ne faisant que travailler
est un rêve qui est plus en plus hors de
portée une fiction au coeur du capital
moral américain dirait youval noah
harari
et jonathan wright en effet les travaux
de piketty ont montré que le rythme de
progression des revenus issus du capital
est supérieur à celui des revenus issus
du travail
pour le dire plus clairement cela veut
dire que ceux qui possèdent déjà du
capital ceux qui possèdent des maisons
qui nous qui peuvent prêter de l'argent
ou encore qui touchent des dividendes
voient leurs revenus croître plus
rapidement que ceux qui se contentent de
travailler et qui compte sur une
augmentation de salaire il suffit
d'avoir beaucoup d'argent pour gagner
beaucoup d'argent
thomas piketty conclut que si ceux qui
possèdent déjà du capital s'enrichissent
plus vite que ceux qui travaillent alors
la seule issue possible c'est ce qu'on
observe en ce moment dans nos économies
développées à savoir une concentration
toujours plus importante des revenus
entre les mains de quelques super riches
et pourtant la réussite notamment
financière est souvent accompagnée d'une
gloire sociale sans doute parce que pour
beaucoup
l'argent sert de proxy pour savoir si
untel a bien travaillé et si il a donc
contribué à la société
al'inverse les chômeurs sont stigmatisés
et beaucoup considèrent que leur
situation économique est une conséquence
mérités de leur manque d'effort et de
contribution à la société
mais les revenus croissants du capital
ont changé quelque chose d'important
gagner de l'argent n'est plus une preuve
de contribution à la société
est ce que le travail d'un trader qui
gagnent des millions est vraiment une
contribution à la société 100 ou 1000
fois plus importante que le travail d'un
chercheur qui découvrirait un vaccin
pour sauver des milliers de vies puis
d'un publicitaire dont la mission est de
créer des besoins comme l'addiction au
tabac ou les jeux d'argent et puis bien
sûr il ya tous ces travaux illégaux
comme les ventes d'armes où les ventes
de drogues illégales ou encore des
emplois qui vise le profit à court terme
uniquement comme ceux qui repose sur
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
ce qui pose la question de la pertinence
du système de l'offre et de la demande
le mécanisme qui permet de fixer les
prix devraient pouvoir tenir compte de
toutes les informations
si une activité polluante alors le
mécanisme de fixation des prix devraient
toutes choses égales par ailleurs
défavorisés cette activité au profit
d'une autre moins polluantes
or ce n'est pas ce qu'on observe en
effet il existe de nombreux dommages
collatéraux qu'on appelle des
externalités liés à certaines activités
dont
épris ne tiennent pas compte ce qui pose
la question les prix doivent t'ils
dépendre uniquement du marché pire
encore l'effort de sauvegarder des jobs
pourrait se faire au détriment de la
société tesla a ainsi annoncé que sa
voiture sans conducteur sera sur le
marché d'ici deux ans voilà qui pourrait
forcer le chômage de centaines de
milliers de personnes dont le travail
consiste essentiellement à conduire un
véhicule
ces centaines de milliers de personnes
vont très probablement former des
syndicats pour demander à sauvegarder
leur métier alors même que remplacer les
conducteurs humains par des véhicules
sans conducteur pourrait sauver des
milliers de vies par an sur les routes
tout en réduisant drastiquement les
coûts de transport et ce ne serait qu'un
début
de nos jours des centaines de milliers
de métier consiste essentiellement à
rentrer des données sur un ordinateur
l'automatisation pourra bientôt
automatiser toutes ces tâches en
réduisant drastiquement le nombre
d'erreurs de saisie tout en améliorant
grandement le service rendu au client
plus besoin de prendre des rendez vous
pendant des heures de travail plus
besoin de remplir des formulaires en
veux tu en voilà
plus besoin de survivre au parcours du
combattant administratif pour refaire
son passeport ouvrir un compte en banque
ou louer un appartement
tout pourrait être fait en une poignée
de cliquer sur un téléphone alors je ne
dis pas ça pour m'attaquer au personnel
administratif
si certains métiers sont plus faciles à
automatiser que d'autres aucun métier
n'a de raison d'être immunisé contre
cette automatisation ingénieurs médecins
avocats professeurs chercheurs
tous ces métiers pourraient être
automatisées d'une manière ou d'une
autre
comme l'expliquent cette superbe vidéo
de sidiki grain et toute cette
automatisation pourra se faire pour le
plus grand bien des clients
certains économistes ont tendance à
poser comme hypothèse que le travail
humain évoluera sans jamais disparaître
or cette hypothèse ne peut évidemment
pas être prouvé ça ne veut pas dire que
cette hypothèse est fausse mais ça ne
veut pas donc plusieurs qu'elle est vrai
et il semble imprudent de ne pas
considérer le cas où le travail humain
disparaîtra même partiellement dans un
monde où le travail est la source de
revenus principale même si ce dernier ne
disparaît pas totalement
que faire si le nombre de travailleurs
nécessaires est largement inférieur à la
taille de la population
il semble même possible qui exigeait
plus de travail pour tous
se fasse au détriment des clients et des
citoyens que nous sommes tous travailler
ou du moins demandé à avoir du travail
pourrait avoir un impact négatif sur nos
sociétés où comme le dirait un
mathématicien dans certains cas et dans
un avenir peut-être pas si éloigné
l'utilité marginale du travail pourrait
être négative et ça si on et
utilitariste ça veut dire qu'il peut
être préférable de ne pas exiger le
travail des humains
tenez c'est que la sacralisation du
travail est sans doute une conséquence
de la sélection de groupes une époque où
travailler était clairement contribué à
la société
or l'émergence des nouvelles
technologies et de l'automatisation
remettent indéniablement en question
cette contribution à la société via le
travail
voilà qui devrait nous inviter à
remettre en question aussi la
sacralisation du travail et en
particulier la stigmatisation des noms
travailleurs en particulier un objectif
récurrent des technologies et la
réduction du travail
on peut ainsi produire beaucoup plus et
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui avec
également beaucoup moins de travail
humain l'automatisation devrait nous
inciter à repenser notre système de
redistribution des richesses
si presque tous les revenus sont issus
de la propriété privée du capital alors
il va falloir repenser notre modèle
économique
de plus à quoi bon produire abondamment
si la majorité de la population sans
emploi et donc sans revenu ne peut pas
en profiter
or ça ça veut dire que même si les
citoyens travaillent beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui
il y a une plus grande abondance de
biens que jamais en termes de théorie
des jeux on est passé d'une situation où
l'économie consistait à produire le plus
grand gâteau possible un peu comme dans
l'épisode 23 à une situation où un
énorme gâteau nous est donné il s'agit
uniquement de bien le partager un peu
comme dans les épisodes 21 et 22
un énorme merci à gilles de la chaîne
eurêka je recommande alors mais alors
très très très très vivement la chaîne
publique a surtout si vous êtes un petit
peu hooligans politique anti finance ou
profinance ou capitaliste vous pas trop
quoi et que vous avez des avis assez
tranché sur toutes ces questions vous
devez absolument voir les chaînes dorées
cas à ce que lorsqu'on découvre
l'économie ou la finance avec eux rien
on se rend compte à quel point c'est
compliqué et que finalement avoir un
avis là dessus c'est super difficile
comme le dirait thibault de la chaîne ne
suffit tout ce qui se passe à côté bank
ce genre de questions sur lesquelles on
a beaucoup dit dennis politique pourrait
dire clairement clairement et et en même
temps c'est des trucs qu'on ne comprend
rien la plupart des gens qui ont des
réactions assez l'épiderme vis-à-vis de
tout ce qui se passe avec les banques
etc
objectivement il je pense qu'en général
ils comprennent pas ce qui se passait
quand on voit ces vidéos là on se rend
compte à quel point on connaît pas bien
du tout les mécanismes qui est derrière
et ses chevaux qui sont elles sont
vraiment utiles ces vidéos pour cette
raison là pour me dire c'est même pas à
hisser le deuil c'est pas les joueurs à
hisser le jeu mais c'est déjà même avant
de lier le jeu et si le comprendre c'est
qu'il est un jeu comme le jeu de
l'économie de la finance déjà c'est un
vieux kick extrêmement difficile à
comprendre vous recommande très vivement
d'essayer de découvrir ce jeu qu'est
l'économie et la finance ils sont des
cheveux super contre actifs super mais
compris entre coups de mal à comprendre
et grâce à lui ils espèrent comprendre
tout ça
de mieux en mieux particulier si vous ne
connaissez pas du tout oreca je vous
recommande de commencer peut-être par la
vidéo où il récapitule tout est aussi
les vidéos sur l'argent que je vous
trouve vraiment fascinante est vraiment
bien fait et puis aussi la vidéo sur le
revenu universel ou à il explique
comment le revenu universel pourraient
permettre de rétablir un certain
équilibre dans le marché du travail et
des enfants n'a parlé du tourisme avec
thibaut de la chaîne monsieur fille qui
lui pend dans cette vidéo j'étais en
fait en vacances népal donc je m'excuse
pour la qualité du son à venir et
j'espère qu'elle vous avez profité des
belles images que vous avez ramené johan
64 à danser à dire que le nono liane 10
mai et dangereux en lui-même
quand j ai oublié mise mais j'entends
aussi cette incapacité à réfléchir une
fois comme on est emporté dans son
raisonnement et quand il faut combattre
les terres tatis tous des gens qu'ils
pensent des promotions sur les 3,7 et
qui rendent à 21 je suis pas sûr que
faire preuve de ligue à nice mais à ce
moment là soit vraiment au lion 30 27
et c'est leur équipe et on le remarque
que l'utilité reste mon pratique est pas
applicable parce qu'il est beaucoup trop
compliqué en effet il faudra savoir tout
ce qui se passe en société en pratique
c'est impossible à savoir
et c'est pour ça que lorsqu'on
utilitariste ce qu'il faut absolument
prendre en compte l'étendue de notre
ignorance et je pense que c'est ça aussi
que les qataris mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'elle nous force à
admettre l'étendue de notre ignorance et
du coup à ne pas avoir des avis sur des
questions politiques sur laquelle on
n'est pas assez informés donc plutôt
qu'une faiblesse je trouve que c'est
plutôt une force de l'utilitarisme et
rachid mohamed amine de faire leur
culture l'autoritarisme utilitariste lui
pose problème
il faut bien voir que pour tous les gens
qui attachent une grande valeur alors
sentiment de liberté c'est mon cas parce
que randonnée dans ce genre de paysage
c'est un sentiment de liberté très très
fort priori l'utilité restée pas
autoritaire par défaut et s'il voit que
j'aime ce sentiment de liberté ils
devraient me laisser surtout si je cause
pas trop de tort aux autres façon plus
générale comme motive on l'a très bien
expliqué dans la vidéo précédente
la plupart des généralistes attache une
grande importance à tout ce qui est
liberté puisque à ce moment là les gens
sont à même de faire ce qui est ce ce
qui est bien selon en fait la liberté
est un instrument utile pour
l'utilitaire east dans beaucoup de cas
mais bien sûr il ne l'est pas tout le
temps qu'il arrive parfois que les gens
ne savent pas exactement ce qui le
rendra bonheur en tout cas pas aussi
bien que quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un
sept autres personnes si elle est utile
car l'histoire a le devoir moral de
faire ce qu'il faut pour rendre à
personne plus heureuse tu compenses et
aux gens qui sont en dépression qui sont
suivis par d'autres personnes qui vont
essayer de les aider contraignant par
exemple ceux qui font penser par exemple
aux addictions aux choses comme ça et de
façon plus générale en temps lorsqu'on
vit en société libertés individuelles
peut être en conflit les unes avec les
autres et de façon parfois très peu
évidente comme c'est le cas notamment
dans le paradoxe de price dont on a
parlé dans l'épisode 16 franchement ça
des trucs les plus fous que j'ai vu
c'est juste notre marché dans le
brouillard et les surveiller pour trois
montagnes avec des yacks et puis est ce
qui montre si juste retrouver mathieu
parce qu'elle nous demande si finalement
le principe ne fais pas aux autres ce
que tu veux pas qu'on te contradictoires
qui est de notamment l'exemple de
schiste en effet quand on y réfléchit
vraiment ce principe déontologique est
pas vraiment un commandement c'est plus
une équation mathématique envie de
lancer définir la liberté des uns
s'arrête là où commence celle des autres
c'est une équation mathématique et là
comme tout est possible des motifs comme
toute équation mathématique c'est pas
dit du lait des émotions ce qui est
encore un argument contre cette fameuse
règle mais normalement je trouve que
penser à un outil d'ariste il se
demandait ce que pense ensuite ariste
c'est quelque chose de très intéressant
ça permet de nouvelles réflexions sur au
fond qu'est-ce qui est bien qu est-ce
qui mal et ça évite surtout de tomber
dans le travers que morales instinctive
qui souvent une wall trade union qui va
chercher à défendre des valeurs ou des
symboles sacrés auquel on est attaché
plutôt qu'à essayer de
raisonner à partir de fondement
quasiment axiomatique de ce que doit
être la morale vous avez aimez cette
vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commenter à la partager pensez à vous
abonner à la cloche pour les futurs
épisodes merci aussi peur pour leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois aujourd'hui les
travailleurs mail s'il le souhaitait ne
peuvent pas se passer de travail alors
que les entreprises elles font tout pour
se passer de travailleurs et elle y
arrive de mieux en mieux la transition
est en marche et même si on peut penser
que les entreprises ne réussiront jamais
à se débarrasser complètement des
travailleurs ça n'empêche pas qu'il
pourrait bien y avoir une part
grandissante de travailleurs sans emploi
de reset bourdy canam exploite 16 h à
canal jimmy